j'étais dans le bol métro donc à ce
moment là avec des amis et puis un type
au moment donné où je descends
escalators m'interpelle en faisant est
en guinée etc tout ça comme d'habitude
je m'arrête pas eu voilà qui me suit
dans l'escalator tout ça il ya là ce
qu'on voit c'est à dire et me filme en
disant ça le cap est tu t'arrêtes pas
etc je vais te parler etc puis vient le
moment où je me retourne et je lui dis
très clairement de la ferme et dans des
termes peu élogieux mais qui l'a bien
cherché donc que tout simplement je dis
de la boucler et après effet une autre
vidéo je crois que c'est lui qu'on voit
en bas là où il dit la prochaine fois je
te vois je te frapper je pas cherché à
discuter et cetera et cetera
donc voilà j'ai un peu l'habitude donc
en fait vous êtes vous étiez agacé parce
que voilà c'est ça vous arrive
maintenant oui tout à fait et donc alors
on va voir la vidéo qui a fait beaucoup
de bruit sur les réseaux sociaux garde
collective
c'est pas comme ça tu roules symbole
transport vient d'un seul pas attendu sa
grosse seul candidat mais moi je voulais
juste pas à les faire je voulais juste
parler je voulais poser de trois
questions là tu prend la tangente que
vous faites des fous derrière les
résoudre quand vous croisez vous prenez
la tangente
voile alors donc vous vous étiez vue
avant ou pas du tout avant vous avez
essayé de parler il a été de vous parler
non moi je suis passé devant lui je me
suis pas arrêté voilà encore un type qui
m'interpelle en dix ans est un geek
c'était en hurlant moi je m'arrête pas
enfin je fais passer j'avais autre chose
à faire donc oui vous a dit je voudrais
te parler ou pas du tout je sais pas ce
qui m'a raconté moi j'étais en train de
descendre jusque là temps avec mes amis
en train de discuter avec eux d'ailleurs
donc je n'avais strictement à rien à
faire de ce qu'ils me racontent et
marquer une façon d'aborder les gens
entre sale [ __ ] c'est
juste un truc non mais c'est sûr mais
aussi les gens étaient pmp si je fais je
veux pas te parler sur le dos le mec qui
m'a insulté il vient de dire oui
je suis pas en train de cautionner ce
qui lui arrive fermer ce qu'il veut
faire de la politique il veut parler aux
gens qu est-ce que c'est la politique
c'est allé parler aux gens quel que soit
le quelles que soient les gens tu peux
pas savoir de quel bord il est quand le
mec il dit est tombé pourquoi il tourne
le dos il parle pas c'est les gens qui
s'énervent
les gens si je cautionne pas attention
tu viens tu es super les gens te
reconnaissent les gens te vois tu es
engagé on t'a vu derrière zemmour on t'a
vu la règle zemmour quand les gens va te
parler pourquoi tu te retombe alors dire
oui qu'est ce qu'il ya où il ya toujours
bien qu autre chose à [ __ ] et j'étais
j'ai fait un match si tu vois parler aux
gens j'étais pas large lorsque je suis
en train de prendre le métro d'accord
y'a quelqu'un qui arrive qui miaule au
visage en disant et tanguy machin et
cetera ce que moi j'en ai rien à faire
vous venez me voir me dit excusez moi je
peux vous parler on avait dit droite les
gens parlent comme ça c'est du sahara et
les gens attendent comme un avis à
arriver
les caisses qui a parce que je sais que
c'est moi tapez vous avez qu à côté bon
ben j'ai dit non mais mieux pour vous
c'est très bien pour moi
[Applaudissements]
mais je crois mais sa version temps
gasquet des gens
il ya des gens éduqués c'est à dire que
les gens qui viennent vous voir qu'ils
disent est ce qu'on peut discuter est ce
qu'on peut et c'est
donc des fois où ça se passe très bien
en fait mais vous avez des gens comme ça
qui vous disent est un geek cette erreur
est un gi merci ça tombe il ya des gens
comme ça c'est à dire c'est tanguy est
pourquoi tu veux pas me parler etc
et qui me disent est engagé à quoi tu
joues et c'est tout ce à quoi tu joues
je suis en train de prendre le métro je
suis pas là pour eux voilà va parler aux
gens
je veux dire voilà la cif